c'est peut-être le dénouement de la
sphère des sondages de l'elysée une
affaire qui a débuté il y à presque 13
en juillet 2009 la cour des comptes
remis un rapport sur les dépenses de
l'elysée c'est une première depuis louis
saez des irrégularités apparaissent dans
la gestion du président nicolas sarkozy
mais rien d'alarmant selon philippe
seguin président de la cour des comptes
ça fait deux cent dix huit ans que le
chef de l'état cache ses comptes à
l'organe de contrôle on va pas se mettre
à faire des roches à celui qui rompt
avec cette tradition ça serait quand
même nous semble-t-il assez un juge mais
l'opposition n'en reste pas là le
recours excessif aux sondages d'opinion
attire leur attention dans le rapport le
budget sondages s'élève à plus de 3
millions d'euros rien que pour 2008
outre le montant ces sondages sont
réalisés sans mise en concurrence par
des entreprises appartenant à des
proches conseillers du président comme
patrick buisson le groupe ps demande
alors la mise en place d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire demande rejetée
au motif que le président de la
république est inattaquable pendant son
mandat la seule explication de cette
décision
c'est sans doute qu'on a soulevé un
véritable scandale avec cette affaire
des sondages et la volonté à tout prix
coûte que coûte me quitte à s'asseoir
sur la constitution de protéger le
président de la république octobre 2012
nicolas sarkozy n'est plus locataire de
l'elysée est donc plus protégé par son
immunité
l'association anticor dépose alors une
plainte pour favoritisme et détournement
de fonds publics cinq ans de sondages
facturés plus de 9 millions d'euros de
nouveaux développements dans la sphère
des sondages de l'elysée sous le
précédent quinquennat
une plainte pour détournement de fonds a
été déposé aujourd'hui par l'association
anticor elle vise indirectement nicolas
sarkozy et patrick buisson qui était
chargé des études d'opinion à l'elysée
des études qui n'auraient pas fait
l'objet d'appel d'offres l'enquêté
ouverte en 2015 patrick buisson le
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy
celui à qui parthenay une des sociétés
de sondages et mise en examen patrick
buisson rattrapé par la sphère des
sondages de l'elysée l'ancien conseiller
de nicolas sarkozy vient d'être mise en
examen pour détournement de fonds
publics notamment des centaines de
sondages auraient été commandés sans
appel d'offres au terme de l'anc est si
proches de nicolas sarkozy sont accusés
de détournement de fonds publics et de
favoritisme renvoyé en correctionnelle
il y aura donc un procès que leur
reproche-t-on exactement des sondages
sont achetés par l'elysée pour plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros d'argent
public jusque là rien d'illégal mais
problème les sociétés sondage en
question appartiennent à des proches de
nicolas sarkozy d'où le délit de
favoritisme
le procès a eu lieu en novembre dernier
le parquet a requis un an de prison
ferme à l'encontre de l'ex conseiller de
l'elysée patrick buisson et six mois à
l'encontre de claude guéant ancien
secrétaire général de nicolas sarkozy
[Musique]